Mark, you have to talk to me, Mark.
Six.
I need to fix this before I go.
I have no idea when you're coming back.
Five main engines start.
Can you have told her you were going to save the world?
No.
Four.
And you become a parent.
Three.
One thing that comes really clear.
Two.
And I just didn't want to make sure your children feel safe.
One.
I'm coming back.
Well, what we found was, you know, the further out into the infinite, we went and the more we isolated these characters,
so we have to go across the universe.
The more the focus naturally becomes on their humanity, you know, on that intimate bond they have,
what makes us human, all those issues.
I think there's something about the starkness and the massiveness of the environment that really reduces this focus very tightly to human bonds and what makes us who we are.
With the robot, we sort of said, let's do the absolute minimalist thing.
Let's say he's a piece of gear like, you know, a tripod or a camera dolly or something,
not something that's supposed to look like a human being.
So he has a personality, the great billow, and you know, puts into the thing.
He was the guy puppeteering a robot, doing the voice of the robot.
And great personality, I think, shines through, but the actual design is very, very utilitarian.
It's really just about function.
And the spaceships are the same.
We didn't want to have any sense of design to them, particularly no, you know, futurist design.
We really wanted to look at what's been used in space, what's been used on the Apollo missions, on the space shuttle, on the ISS,
and every switch does what it needs to do, and every button does something.
And, you know, all the docking mechanisms, all those things.
We're all just based on contemporary reality of how do you deal with life in space?
What we were able to do is look back, and this is something I like doing,
sort of looking back at the great achievements of the past, and avail ourselves of those techniques.
So miniature work, motion control, things like that, they pioneer.
But then combining that with today's technology, which allows you to composite things in a particular way.
UCG, in a particular way, to enhance those types of effects.
So we really tried to build on what's been done before, but add our own techniques to it.
And there are quite a few things in the film that have never been done before, and may never be done again.
I don't know, but certainly mixing and varying our techniques, using some old, some new, I think helps really disguise the trickery involved in the film.
Because obviously it's all, you know, artificial at the end of the day, but it felt real to us making it,
and hopefully it feels real to the audience watching it.
Do not go gentle into that good night.
Old age should burn and rave a closer day.
Rage, rage against the dying of the light.
All right, are you ready? Yes, you are.
We all find a way that we always have.